former Las Vegas Raiders player Henry
rugs pleading guilty to driving drunk at
more than 150 miles per hour killing a
young woman and her dog now as part of a
police settlement rugs will go to prison
prosecutors saying a key piece of
evidence likely would have never made it
to trial eight news now investigator
David charns talking exclusively with
the district attorney to find out why
do you please
former Raiders wide receiver Henry ruggs
accepting a plea deal that will put him
in prison for three to ten years without
the possibility of probation
yes sir rugs admitting in court that he
killed 23-year-old Tina tintor and her
dog Max in November 2021 while he was
impaired in driving at 156 miles an hour
this video 8 news now obtained showing
his car streaked by why did we get to
this plea agreement
you know this is an agonizing case David
Clark County district attorney Steve
Wolfson says they didn't want to take a
chance that rugs's blood results which
showed a level twice the legal limit
would not be entered into evidence if
there were a trial we believe that there
was a strong likelihood that the blood
alcohol evidence would be suppressed and
without that blood test and evidence we
don't have a felony DUI charge rugs
attorneys argued police had no probable
cause to take a sample of their client's
blood because though he had just caused
a fatal crash they could not verify
impairment a police officer in good
faith that called the judge for the
warrant gave very very few facts to
support
the probable cause that he was impaired
transcripts revealing officers did not
mention anything regarding possible
intoxication to the judge who signed off
on that warrant saying rugs was quote
driving at a high rate of speed and
going in and out of traffic before the
Collision they added was rug's passenger
who admitted to drinking earlier in the
night not rugs without the evidence
Wolfson says all that would have been
left was a reckless driving charge
something that could have left rugs with
possibly just probation under this
settlement Mr rugs is going to prison
he's getting a prison sentence of 10
years with the chance at getting out
after three tintor's family sang in a
statement No sentence will ever bring
Tina and Max back but we hope that
everyone learns from this preventable
incident so that no other families
suffer like we do we appreciate the
efforts of the District Attorney's
office to overcome the issues caused by
the initial investigation and we look
forward to putting this behind us so
that we can focus on honoring the
memories of Tina and Max
rugs is out on bail his
charms 8 News Now
so rug's attorney also releasing a
statement calling the crash a quote
accident they say in part Henry entered
his plea today in hopes that it will
further the process of healing the
wound's cause by the accident they say
they will say more once their client is
sentenced in August Metro also telling
us officers did not administer any field
sobriety test as rugs was taken to the
hospital for his injuries at the time of
that incident they add quote no legal
outcome can ever make the tintor family
whole again but we'd hope that this
brings some level of closure to the
family following Tina's horrific death